he knows absolutely outrageous the fact
that governments are working with big
Tech and together they are deciding
what's misinformation and what's not
misinformation and we're finding that
what's regarded as misinformation is
constantly changing this is so dangerous
because it allows governments to push
their narratives to push their
propaganda and nobody's talking about
this that's why we desperately need a
decentralized alternative internet and
we need it now and I'm not really seeing
many people doing this there is one
project which I came across called
tominet they're creating a decentralized
internet there's no CEO there are a few
Founders or team leaders but those
individuals aren't in control of it the
Dow is in control of it and they can
vote to get rid of certain team leaders
if they don't want them and so it's
fully democratized it's Democratic and
it's fair